[Music]
so today I'm gonna do something
different I'm gonna share with you some
of my card collection yes like high-end
card collection because I know I got
some messages from you saying some of
you pad I read some forums that you want
two million dollars worth of cards is it
right as a nod right can you share some
of the pieces I'm doing it for you today
and by the way here's what I'm doing it
there's a reason behind the madness let
me explain to what the reason behind the
madness is so I'm not the only one that
collects weird things let me give you
some names Angelina Jolie collects
knives I don't know why but she collects
knives Nicolas Cage collects comic books
matter of fact he owned a Superman
number one the old old-school the main
one and by the way somebody stole it
from him and then he eventually found it
back and they brought it back to him and
he sold it recently for 2.1 million
dollars a comic book he saw for 2.1
million dollars Robin Williams Billy
Crystal and Charlie Sheen collect
baseball cards I want to say Brad Pitt
collects metal furniture Tom Hank elects
typewriters jay-z collects watches
there's a list of these names of what
people collect I like baseball cards and
there was a reason why I collect
baseball cards so when I was a kid when
I was a kid I used to go around
collecting beer bottles late at night my
mom and my sister would go to sleep I
would take my shopping cart and I would
go from trash cans and I will collect
two liter bottles because it was five
cents per 2-liter bottle and it / - cans
I would get five cents at Albertsons and
I would go I would go recycle and I
would go take that money that I have my
friend Adrienne and we would go and we
would buy baseball cards and I always
wanted to have this 1992 Stadium Club
Shack when he was coming out of LSU it
was a card I was like $40 costs not a
big deal but to me it was a big deal so
and the first time I started collecting
cards I was in Germany when Germany won
the World Cup in 1990 I was in Germany
everything shut that for a week I was in
Germany when they won the World Cup
and it was the first time I collected
cards and then later on it got bigger
and I remember I said in 1991 I never
forget this Bruce McNall and Wayne
Gretzky bought a card in 1991 it was a
Honus Wagner card T 206 they bought it I
want to say four four hundred and fifty
one thousand dollars
is what they bought it for that card
they bought in 1991 for 450 1000 dollars
today I want to say sold a couple years
ago for 7.5 million dollars and by the
way if you know anybody who has that
card please send me a tweet I'd like to
talk to them I handle this Patrick made
David send me a tweet I'd like to talk
to the person that owns the Honus Wagner
car but the point is think about four
hundred and fifty one thousand dollars
you buy something for 450 450 one in
what is it sell for today a house if you
would about in 1991 for 451 what is it
worth today a million maybe maybe
million 1 million to one card from four
fifty one to seven and a half million so
this is my card collection what I have
let me share it with you the first one
is a jerry west rookie card now if you
know who Jerry West is he's on the NBA
logo when he see the NBA logo Jerry West
is the logo that's that's why they call
him Velo go this is a 1961 Philly or
seven and a half Beckett graded services
it's probably a $5,000 card but Jerry
was you know he's the greatest gym and
MBA today he goes to a team they pretty
much won a championship or go to the
finals or go and do things no one
expected them to do like Memphis
Grizzlies did when they hired him as a
consultant but this is a legendary
player there's a lot of history behind
it so I wanted to own a rookie card I
did the next one is a Mickey Mantle 1953
tops it's a BB G 7 by Beckett this is
probably a $13,000 card Mickey Mantle
Mickey Mantle was a stud coming up I was
always a big Mickey Mantle fan so this
isn't the 1952 Topps card so this is the
1953 tops but it's still a great car to
have the next one is a world Chamberlain
rookie card PSA 8 1961 Fleer obviously
Wilt Chamberlain is an anomaly this guy
claimed he benched 600 pounds jumped 51
inches and he's the only guy ever to
average 50 points in a game and I think
45 rebounds and again which is insanity
to average those kinds of rebounds and
then they told him you were ba Hager you
don't pass in one season he went out
there and averaged 12.4
I think assists again and he led the
league in assists a seven foot one guy
let the game in assists but that's Wilt
Chamberlain this is probably a fifteen
thousand dollar card you're looking at
what a world Chamberlain the next one is
a Babe Ruth card PSA five
gaudí this one obviously Babe Ruth if
you if you know nothing about baseball
cards and you're thinking about it
messing into baseball cards pick players
and don't go to modern go pre
70s go pre 60s if you could even better
but if you can get any Babe Ruth cars
that are greater by PSA you keep them
for a while it's gonna do okay for you
this is probably fifteen thousand dollar
car it's probably at $13,000 cards still
a nice card the next one is a Ted
Williams 1939 play ball this is probably
Ted Williams best rookie best card he
can get and I want to say this is a
rookie card
PSA eight I think one of these sold
recently for 42 K Ted Williams won
Triple Crown pre World War because he
went to the war he says I'm gonna go to
war so one day just decides I'm going to
war he goes to war he wants a Triple
Crown then goes to war comes back from
war Edwin's
Triple Crown again last guy who batted
406 baseball players today get paid
twenty thirty million dollars year to
hit three out of ten pitches this guy
would hit four out of ten pitches if he
was playing today he'd be making sixty
seventy eighty million dollars here and
that's probably lowball and the number
that he'd be worth he'd be the first
billion dollar contract if he played
today but that's Ted Williams I'm a big
Ted Williams fan because psychologically
he played with the media he was a
brilliant guy outside of just playing
baseball Joe DiMaggio okay Joe DiMaggio
is known for a lot of things one of the
things he's known for is a 56 game hit
streak 56 games around he got a hit the
other thing he's famous for is he
married the woman that was on the first
ever Playboy magazine which is Marilyn
Monroe many many men admired and they
fantasize about Marilyn Monroe this guy
didn't have to fantasize because every
night he went home it wasn't a fantasy
was a reality with Marilyn Monroe didn't
last a long time but he was at least
with her for a while this is a PSA 8
1938 Goudy there's probably a $42,000
card thirty to thirty five to forty two
thousand dollar card and again another
good car to add to your collection now
it gets a little bit interesting the
next one is a Babe Ruth this is card
number 149 it's part of the same
collection but in that collection they
had a few Babe Ruth this one's card
number 144 this is 149 this is PSA 5
this is PSA 8 this sold in
2016 for a hundred and fifty five
thousand dollars is what it sold three
years ago for 155 again you cannot go
wrong with Babe Ruth especially if you
can get a PSA eight which this is just a
beauty I mean this card right here can
you imagine like cards come out kids
grab them they're messed up and you need
to tell me this one's got Center surface
corners just a gorgeous card here Babe
Ruth first man to its 60 home runs I
think Roger Maris broke his record in
1961 with 61 home runs and people were
upset that he broke the record and he
was psychologically tortured so much
because everybody loved they root so
much and Roger wasn't ever a superstar
he was a low-key guy they did a movie
about him but anyways that's Babe Ruth
now we're getting interesting now it's
getting interesting here with some of
the cards I show you this one here this
is a 1979 Wayne Gretzky PSA 10 rookie
card tops not opechee this is the tops
one there's only two of these in the
world great at PSA 10 and by the way
this one sold again three four years ago
for two hundred and five thousand
dollars is what this one sold for again
Gretzky the only sport that I would say
where it's no debate in football
everybody can debate who is the greatest
football player of all time I'll be you
know it's really Barry Sanders no it's
not very sanest I'm bright it's not Tom
Brady it's you know Elway it's not Elway
it's really you know Peyton Manning what
are you talking about it Emmitt Smith
it's there's a debate basketball LeBron
Colby Jordan will Kareem hockey no
debate baseball debate there is no
debate this is the goat and no one's
even close and no one debates it nobody
there is no debate with hockey so this
is one of the cards but the other one is
the crazy one let me show you this one
here and you can go research it for
yourself this is a 1979 opechee Wayne
Gretzky rookie card they look identical
right but one is tops one is OPG top so
for 205 this one I want to say in 2016
sold for four hundred and sixty five
thousand dollars this one so for for 65
this is when you go into psays
headquarters in Newport Beach with the
PSAs where they Grady
cards and Joe was there when these
things were being retold and a new
holder this is brand new holder I don't
say six weeks ago or something like that
four weeks ago we have the whole print
out and everything and they have
registered it but when you go there on
the wall of PSA they have this on the
wall when you enter a PSA headquarters
office this is on the wall this card is
on the wall it's a special card again
Wayne Gretzky there's a story behind the
fact that I you know was enamoured by
the fact that him and Bruce McNall
bought a Honus Wagner card in 1919 1920
by and his rookie card and it's worth I
didn't buy it for for 65 but it's worth
so three years ago for 65 minutes three
years ago who knows what it's worth
today I know there's a guy that owns
these who is a very close customer and
friend of ours with true heritage and he
wouldn't sell his if you offered him
$750,000 he wouldn't sell his he's
sitting on it he's not selling it he's a
die-hard Gretzky fan but the other one
is here so why am i sharing this with
you let me explain to why I'm sharing
this with you it's very simple look you
know how in life to win there's
different recipes meaning you need hard
work you need goals you need targets you
need clarity you need to recruit the
right people you need an enemy you need
competition you know you need you know
all these you need to be able to figure
out a way to hang out with people at
your same level so you don't feel like
you have anxiety because like other
people are going through the same
problems you have a person you look up
there that's mentoring you any people
below you that you're mentoring all of
these things you know what's the
additional thing I would add to that you
need to have side hobbies or collections
that bring out the childlike tendency of
you because when I hold these cards I go
back to the 12 year old kid the 12 year
old kid I'll tell you crazy story about
the 12 year old kid when I was in Wilson
junior high school which is in Glendale
it was a middle school and I was in
eighth grade and we would walk back we
would have to go down to going over the
bridge and when we would walk down this
place my friends would walk with me and
I would ask him the interesting question
remember when we were boys or he would
ask and say if you could be with any
woman who would it be oh my gosh for me
it's Pamela Anderson from Baywatch
because back then it was very much
for me it's Sophia Loren I still think
she is gorgeous I think it's Elizabeth
Taylor you're out of your mind you're
you guys don't know what you're talking
about the most beautiful woman is Jada
Pinkett I was
diehard Jada Pinkett fan Jada Pinkett
are you crazy why Jada Pinkett and we
would go back and forth or even the
debates about you know I don't know if
you've done this one this one was a lot
of fun
I grab my friends and we'd sit down we
talk and I would say listen guys you got
one of these four you can be which one
would you rather be richest man in the
world at the time it was gates you can
be the greatest athlete in the world
Michael Jordan you can be the greatest
performer in the world Pickett Michael
Jackson or it can be the most powerful
in the world a president who would you
like to be and we would start oh there's
no way in the world I would want to be
the basketball player who cares about
basketball it's a sport after you're
done it's over are you kidding me I want
to be in that because if your basketball
everybody watches you the billionaire
the president and the Hollywood stars
and enter - everybody watches you you
are if you're the president you make
decisions if you're a billionaire you
buy everything that was a mindset right
because it was a dream right and
sometimes when you get past a certain
age after you beat up so many times in
life the first thing that goes is that
dream machine so you go from the
languages what if one day we could go
out there and live a life like this and
be able to have this and be able to have
that versus it goes to what if we go out
of business what if somebody comes after
me what if I lose everything the what if
starts the same way but it used to go
this way now goes this way you got to
figure out a way to bring it from this
side to this side by re-energizing
yourself and going back to being
childlike not childish childlike so I
made a video I want you to watch called
the 11 reasons why the best
entrepreneurs are childlike click on the
thumbnail to go watch it and we'll put
in the description as well but the whole
idea is for you to start going back to
dreaming again
when you do people want to be around you
you recruit better people clients want
to be around you people want to do
business with you you become attractive
again because you're dreaming again
right so this is just for me you may say
Pat I could care less or I cannot
believe you paid you know how much money
you paid half a million dollars for what
for a piece of paper I would never do
something like that
that's fine but it doesn't matter if
you're like what I like maybe you like
the watches maybe you're like a comic
book
maybe you're like jewelry maybe you like
a certain stamp maybe you're like coins
go get it and look at it and appreciate
it and it takes you back to what you
were like when you were six
eight ten eleven twelve years old cause
it brings back that childlike tendency
anyways having said that if you got
anything you collect I want to read
about it post it down in the comment
section and if you know anybody that has
a Honus Wagner card or the Mickey Mantle
PSA ten card I'm a qualified buyer send
me a tweet at Patrick Bay David I would
love to talk to you don't know for new
business together or not but I'll have
to have a conversation with you take
everybody again if you haven't so please
do so as well all right